Part of the work I've done with couples revolves around kind of the sexual
scripts, which are the sexual response cycles that I see couples come in with.
And it's almost like they have this preconditioned idea that this is the story
I'm supposed to have for sex and if it doesn't go this way, then there's
something wrong. And so, I have to talk with him about, you know what, that's
just the story that we have in the United States, mainly from this medical
point of view. But, you can write your sexual script any way you want. So, it
doesn't have to end in orgasm. It doesn't have to start out with this massive
building up of desire and excitement. it can go any way that you want it to and
that's what's really important as people need to understand that they really
own their sexual response cycle. And they own their sexual script. And it
really can be written and rewritten any way that's, that's comfortable for
them. So we know that there's a difference in sexual response depending on the
culture but do women and men have different orgasms. Even though a lot of
people orgasms whether it be through self stimulation self love or partnered or
partnered experiences, many people do orgasms. However, there are large
percentages of people who do not. again a lot of times that does tend to be
women who experience more difficulty orgaziming. On average, the orgasm, kind
of experience is the shortest part of a sexual response cycle. Unless of
course, you're, you know, a pig in which case, it's like thirty minutes long.
But, humans are very short cycled for their orgasm but that really varies from
person to person as well. So, for some people an orgasm might last like thirty
seconds, for other people it could last a matter of minutes. and actually woman
tend to have longer orgasms than men. or are capable of longer orgasms. Women,
when they do orgasm are also able to have multiple orgasms pretty consecutively
in a row pretty easily compared to their male counterpart. So, once a woman
kind of figures out how to have an orgasm, she actually has more opportunity
for longer orgasms and more of them in comparison to men. However in general,
more women do struggle to kind of learn how to orgasm. And I say learn how to
orgasm because one of the biggest differences is just is an, it's an anatomical
difference, right. So men they have basically all of their equipment right in
front of them on the outside, you know, their penis is right in front of them,
their testicles is right in front of them. So it's, it's very easy to kind of
self explore and figure it out what to do, right. With women, most of the
equipment is internal. so it's very difficult to kind of figure out what, what
your body's doing, what something feels like. I mean and there's a difference
between a clitoral orgasm and a
[INAUDIBLE]
spot orgasm or a G-spot orgasm. And a lot of women, it takes a lot of
exploration before they're really able to have an orgasm in either location.
And a lot of the holdup for women is just that many societies, pretty much
across the globe, many societies have put restrictions on women. social
restrictions, moral restrictions, religious restrictions where they're, they're
kind of sent this message that sex is something that they're not supposed to
enjoy. And doesn't really, their needs really aren't all that important in
terms of desire, arousal and orgasm. And so, it's very challenging to, for
women not only because it's anatomical differences to orgasm because we have to
learn. But they also have to tear down kind of this societal block or wall that
has been created in their mind around not being able to orgasm. So, couple
things I recommend for people when I see clients, especially women who are
struggling to have an orgasm and they want to have an orgasm. It's okay if
people don't want to orgasm too. That's fine. but what I recommend when they do
is, a lot of self exploration, so getting to know their own body. And then a
lot of, just cognitive behavioral therapies to work on the fact that it's
totally normative and natural to have sexual feelings and to feel good when
you're engaging in certain behaviors.